Service workers implies some subtle
changes and application architecture.
Rather than squashing all of your
application into an HTML string,
we need to do things AJAX style.
Request the data asynchronously
from the server and
then update the local DOM to match.
This is where you have a shell
that's always cast and
can always boot up without the network.
And the content that is refreshed
regularly and managed separately.
So, what goes into
the application shell?
The first step is to break the design
down into it's core components.
Ask yourself,
what needs to be on screen immediately?
What other UI components
are key to our app?
What supporting resources are needed for
the app shell?
For example, JavaScript, Styles, etc.